bonjour c'est frédéric taddeï je vous
donne rendez vous le 31 janvier à 20
heures pour un interdit d'interdire
exceptionnelle en public et en direct au
théâtre du rond-point pour l'ouverture
du festival nos disques sont rayés à
deux mois de la présidentielle je
recevrai brandt deux heures emmanuel
todd marcel gaucher céline spector clara
hugues r nicolas framont et françois
bousquet pour débattre de ce qui fait
peuple aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'un
peuple où est le peuple que veulent les
peuples la question du peuple est de
retour alors pour celles et ceux qui ne
pourraient pas venir au théâtre
l'émission sera visible en direct sur
les réseaux sociaux d'ayrté france à
bientôt
[Musique]